hi guys just wanted to quickly say that
I have some pretty exciting news to tell
you at the end of this video so I'll see
you then
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's been a couple days of me just being
sat indoors looking a mess feeling a bit
of a mess and working on this game but
today is Wednesday and this is the day
that I've invited people to play my game
so I'm still not happy for them to play
it but they should do because I'm not
finished yet but this will hopefully
maybe point out things I didn't think
about and also I'm thinking like are
things as obvious as I think they are
you know like the controls and stuff
like that so I'll figure that out I'm
gonna go unique early try and get some
more work in and I think I've got some
instructions that I need to put in that
I hadn't thought about just like I was
playing it and it just there was parts
of it that didn't make sense but we'll
see today when my friends play the game
I'm scared I want to try and get this
game finished at least by Friday because
that is two full days before my deadline
and then I have to write like a journal
and make sure that my website is done
and like a LinkedIn profile and stuff
and I have all that anyway but I just
need to update it and make sure that
it's good to hand in and I need to like
do a lot of documents alongside the game
so it'll be good if I had a full weekend
for that but knowing me I'm probably
gonna want to fit something in the
game's getting huge now though it's like
9 gig I just keep adding things like
this morning I woke up early and it
added a webcam function that reads if
you have a webcam device and if you do
it's added like another element to the
key I just I just have fun there it's
just fun anyway
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to unique and
actually go outside instead of just look
outside all the time yeah I'll see you
when I get there I love this at least I
did something right the video if nothing
else
no scare you Kris mo much but if I had
this in my probably that's the old us Oh
what's all is that Oh
have you given me those yet okay sorry I
didn't put the moments I'll do that in a
bit Dory's cuz it's undeveloped movers
so that's just for me oh that's fine
yeah yeah you just saw her Faro play
testing the game and with play testing
it's always kind of scary because it's
exciting because you get to see how
people will respond and it's like
rewarding but at the same time it's so
huh because you realize that when people
don't know the game they're not gonna
necessarily go where you think they're
gonna go or do what you think they're
gonna do is always like oh my gosh they
find bugs you didn't realize were there
so I've got a few things due tonight but
I think we're getting there guys we are
getting there
it is 2:12 and the morning I'm currently
listening to this wonderful soundtrack
yes I'm quite proud of myself
so James the producers have me some
wonderful sound effects of him doing
some choking sounds and crying sounds
but there were always short snippets and
I needed to have an ongoing kind of loop
so I managed to put them all into an
array and then iterate through that
array of wait until each clip had
finished with each clip as a different
length and then play a random
next chopping sound so this will never
sound the same yeah I know I'm feeling
pretty smart right now mr. Bristo hyung
you don't even know me small wins
bedtime see ya
Tiff's getting around today to give me
the rest of the environment like the
final environments although we might we
might redo it for the grad show but yeah
happy now
yeah hold on need after changing yeah I
I think it's coming along yeah hola
it is now Friday so I've got three days
until my deadline so someone on
something my face or something on the
lens it might be my face anyway I think
the hardest thing for me is knowing when
to stop because I play it and I'm like
oh we soaked all of this did that or if
that did that or added this or do that
or like I I've now added a freaking
security camera and I've just spent ages
like positioning it in the right place
and seeing if maybe I should make it
look at the character if they go through
a collider but that didn't really work
out so now it's a stationary and and if
you look at it there's nothing happens
and it's like I need to just chill and
just stick with what I've got and that's
the hardest thing for me it's not
getting carried away with all these
ideas but I'm pretty happy with how it
is right now I'm just gonna keep on
working I'm sorry I'm not very good at
vlogging all this I just get I get so in
the mind space and it's it's all I can
think about yeah we have two days so
deadlines today oh gosh today I'm gonna
try and get all the kind of finishing
touches done so everything I definitely
want to do like all the audio and the
lights basically most of the bugs are
pretty much done now and I've still got
ideas like I really want to add into the
game but I'm like no I can add them in
later for you guys but for my deadline I
need to stick to the brief stick to my
storyboard don't go too overboard and
then I can get overboard later at my
spare time because I have
the time in the world for that that's
all right now I just get food because I
just forgot to buy food but I did only
have time to buy food so I'm going for a
run to buy food because save time and I
mean I guess it's healthy and it's good
to get other house because then when
you're out the house you kind of
thinking about things that maybe you
camp in just perspective when you're in
the working environment aka the bedroom
yeah that's my little bit of advice for
the day wish me luck
I'm back from my run actually where I
went to the shops bought some food I
feel good because I've just been like
sitting on this chair this chair it's
not it's not a comfy chair it's it's
really not it's just came with the room
and my legs were like so much pain but
anyway so I went to the shops there's
this like weird guy at the shop actually
story time
please there was this weird guy at the
shops and he was commenting on like what
I was buying and I was looking it's the
stuff he's like oh it's a hard choice
isn't it I was like yeah yeah it's
really hard choice and then he was like
whatever is the most healthiest I guess
and I was like whatever's the most
cheapest really and then he was like no
because then you just end up eating junk
food and I was that like holding bananas
and spinach and I was like and my
porridge and also I think I'm doing all
right
hey I think there's more don't like have
a nice day let's get on with this game
[Applause]
so it's de de de bullet it's the day
before deadline day it's day before
d-day game is tiny done I was waiting
just for a one or two more assets so I'm
just gonna put them in I spent so long
trying to make my shadow show because
they showed in unity but they didn't
show in the build and oh my gosh there's
there's so many little things that you
have to think about like obviously like
mapping and baking correctly not baking
cakes baking lights but also setting up
your quality settings and your player
settings making sure that the cameras
are deferred turns out my pixel light
setting the default one on you see is
four and that was not enough to render
all of my lights and my shadows so yeah
it just was not looking good but I fixed
it and I'm so excited and there's still
bugs and things that I definitely want
to change before I allow you guys to see
it but I think it's good for deadlines
so I'm pretty happy and now I'm just
making some food and now I need to do my
website and everything else I've
actually got a website is yazmin seed
okay okay so just so you know doing it
tell them the knees
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh we finally hand it in after
all the stress and now we can sleep and
okay hey I finished oh my gosh it still
doesn't feel real like everyone's like
how do you feel now that you've you've
done your deadline you've got you're
working and I'm just like no but I kind
of don't want to think about it either
because that means I have to think about
the future and like what path I want to
take you know film or games and like ah
it's it's scary but at the same time
super exciting and just being able to
edit these vlogs back made me really
proud of myself because I remember
filming the moon just being like this
makes no sense
and I I was tired and I hadn't slept and
just all these things but you know
seeing me be so happy at points about
little tiny wins and stuff I was just
like mother oh yes well them me past me
and I did actually get some questions on
the last game dev vlog video so I
figured I would just answer that it's
from a user that I really can't say your
name I'm so sorry I even typed into
Google how to pronounce it and Google
was like yeah so really sorry so
initially you asked me if I use anything
like get and they have done in the past
when I was working as like a web
developers and it was really good for
group projects and things like that if
multiple people are coding but because I
was the only coder on this game it just
didn't really make sense to I mean maybe
people use it for other things than just
code like do they use it for storing
models and stuff I don't think so from
my experience has just been code because
I knew you can like pile and push and
get someone's code and
add to it and then put it back up there
it's kind of got a hosting space but no
because I was the only coder
I didn't used to get before this what we
did use instead there was just a Google
Drive and then I would put everything in
folders and I was like this is for
materials so concept art blah blah blah
blah and people would just upload there
so we did have like a hosting space you
also asked about the specs of the
computer that I used to develop this
game so actually I'll put the exact
laptop that I bought cuz I did buy
myself a new PC gaming laptop so I'll
put that in the description below if you
want to have a look at the exact one
that I was using that's probably a lot
easier to tell you and you asked will I
publish this game will it be available
on Steam that's sweet
I don't think I could get it on steam
but maybe I could put it on like
gamejolt
or something like that at the moment
like I was saying in the vlogs there's
definitely more that I want to do before
it gets to you guys I have so many ideas
and I have some of my own 3d bottles
that I couldn't put in this game because
it wouldn't work for the deadline
because I wasn't the 3d modeler but I
want to use them in the game so that you
guys can see them because I'm proud of
them and stuff so yeah there's stuff
that I want to add in there and do more
of but um I'll definitely publish it
probably be gamejolt I don't know steam
would be great I just don't think I'm at
that level but we shall see I will keep
you informed
so now and now for the big reveal for
the exciting news that I told you that
was a thing at the beginning of this
video basically I am so freakin lucky I
keep this because I have been chosen to
be one of the use of star players of
2018 and I will be going to e3 to play
all the games and basically just
represent Ubisoft
frickin awesomeness and I am just so
excited I can't believe it's come so
soon it's only a couple of weeks until
III and I'm gonna be there so mugiwara
on twitter did ask me are you going to
vlog being at e3 and hell yes if there's
anything in particular that you really
want to see behind the scenes over e3 or
any games that you're super looking
forward to please let me know in the
comments below or tweet me at rag man x
because i'll be there i'll be vlogging
getting as much content i'm personally
really looking forward to death
stranding the new trailer that he was
working on any tweet about a Poteau
about a photo so excited about that i'm
i've been watching all the theories i'm
just trying to like link together all
the things and of course i wanna see if
there's more beyond Knievel 2 news
anyway thanks so much for joining me in
this journey and being so so patient
while I was making this game and
finishing University now I'll have more
time to do more content for you more
live streams with you and I am working
tirelessly with my producer of rides and
productions to finish off this EP we've
got two songs done once kind of getting
there and hopefully we'll have four
songs so yeah a lot of exciting things
very Wow overwhelms yeah no I'm just me
to be overwhelmed if I'm honest but yeah
please do let me know what are you
looking forward to 83 what content do
you want me to make when I'm out there
and of course have a lovely day or
evening bye